hi my name is Abby Brown and I teach at
Torrey Pines High School in San Diego
California
my presentation is 3d printing in high
school with Mathematica I'll be sharing
my early experiences using 3d printers
even as an experienced Mathematica user
well hi everyone my name is Abby Brown
and I teach at Torrey Pines high school
in San Diego California and it's always
good to be back to the Wolfram
technology conference I like like
enjoying seeing familiar faces as well
as new faces typically when I've been
doing presentations here in the past has
been me introducing my students I have
some students here this year but they're
going to be presenting in the next talk
at 1:30 with Eric Nelson about project
work they've done through augment
software this year I get to present
about a project that I've been doing for
the past few months and that is 3d
printing so I've been working with
Mathematica since the mid-1990s and have
been including Mathematica in my
teaching for about 20 years and but I'm
much newer to the world of 3d printing
it's something that's been in the back
of my mind for a long time and just last
school year my school received two 3d
printers through a grant for our career
technical education program in
particular our CAD classes that we have
but once I learned there were 3d
printers on campus I knew I had to get
my hands on them and in fact the first
people to get their hands on it were a
couple of my students who were also
taking the CAD class and the CAD teacher
didn't know how to use them either so we
kind of turn it over the students who
figured out how to use the printers and
then they in turn taught me and my
colleague mr. John tater so and today
I'm going to share with you a couple of
my favorite stories from the early days
of printing along with several of the
different strategies I've used with some
of the challenges and things that I've
come across through them and I would
like I'm going to share a couple of
projects done by my students and wrap it
up with some additional concluding
thoughts for anybody unfamiliar with 3d
printing and its process it's there's
actually kind of three steps that go
along with it in I use Mathematica to
create models which then get exported to
STL files
and then I use another program we use
simplify 3d but there's several
different programs out there that
interprets the STL file and lets us
figure out the support material and the
exact information to talk to the printer
so that it can produce the model in the
end and it exports that as g code which
is then interpreted by the 3d printer so
a lot of times when I'm showing this to
what do you think I can just plug in
Mathematica to the printer and just hit
print and go but it's much more
complicated than that is anybody who
hasn't been involved with 3d printing
knows so one of my favorite stories
actually comes from my first day of 3d
printing so the students showed me some
things I went home and I printed
something and I was so excited and I
brought it to lunch that day because I
got it printed that first thing in the
morning and I showed it to a few of the
other math teachers and one of the other
calculus teachers just lit up
and he said I've always wanted models
for these calculus problems in
particular number 61 and this worksheet
that I do and then for tickets these
solids of known cross-sections so he
emails this to me immediately after
lunch I and I'm like solids have known
cross-section I know I did some code for
that awhile ago and I went to my abbe
math website and I found code that I had
written 15 years ago and it still works
in Mathematica and all I had to do was
change the equations to match the
problem and I produce my model and then
I got to use this print out 3d function
that I had heard about in Mathematica
and the next morning I set it up to
print and by lunchtime the next school
day I had the model in hand for my
colleague so it was 24 hours later even
with only one day of printing experience
using that 15 year old Mathematica code
and the power of printout 3d I was able
to create a model and shortly thereafter
I was anticipating a lesson in my
multivariable calculus class where we
figure out the maximum minimum and
saddle points of a surface in fact I'm
teaching this on Monday and this is what
it looks like when I teach the lesson
and we're we doing
example so I have this big example we go
through it all and I said we have a
surface with a maximum in three saddles
what on earth could that look like and
we try to sketch the contour plot and
then of course for the last several
years I can bust out Mathematica and say
oh here's what our surface looks like
here's the contour plot and then last
spring when I was just learning how to
do 3d printing I couldn't do more and so
we I took the surface set it up with the
printing and was able to then reveal the
surface to the class and the students
could have it in hand so now they have
the opportunity to actually feel and
understand really what does a saddle
point look like and this is a screenshot
of simplified 3d where you're able to
view the kind of a preview of how it
will print but what was fascinating to
me about this was when I looked at it
from the top down and here I just have
sort of a few screenshots I shared this
with the students to help them
understand the process of 3d printing
that we were doing right there on campus
and immediately they recognized what
they were seeing here were the contours
those level curves Oh everyone's got
chance to see everybody those level
curves that we were just talking about
earlier in the chapter and again with
this same problem and so here we have
this real world hands-on application of
these multivariable concepts that we've
been working through so what are some of
the strategies that I've been using to
create 3d models so this I created I've
wanted one for 20 years a little thing
to help me under straight how curl works
and I wanted to bring it but I wasn't
sure I was gonna get that through
airport security it's about eight inches
long so I decided it wasn't worth the
risk and I left it at home
so I you could build something like this
in graphics 3d very easily you don't
need much code for that but what I was
finding that when I would export to STL
in Mathematica elements might be missing
so here the ball was just missing so I
changed it to sphere and it shows up but
then when I preview
since I would notice there's a lot of
gaps and so those gaps matter the
printer would actually not print
something there and then things would
become and stable or break apart and I
have other examples where primitives
like would be I would want them like
interlocking and they would fill in very
weird ways and I could tell that even if
I tried printing it the whole thing
would fall apart so graphics 3d also
can't control the resolution and I
really like nice smooth surfaces and so
the I've learned that these details
print so even though these you know you
had a glance it's a sphere and a
cylinder all of those individual
polygons would actually show with the
high resolution that the printer can
attain so region plot 3d is kind of some
other another way I've been going try
and explore things in particular because
I can control the plot points and up the
resolution but this has a huge issue
with calculation time and file size so
just preparing this talk I ran this with
different levels of plot points and it
took 42 minutes to get this one at 100 I
tried running 300 plot points is which
what I had originally printed it at and
after all my computer running a whole
day of school I just killed it so it
took several hours and it didn't even
finish so that can be very impractical
when you're trying to create models and
edit things even in preparing this talk
switching from eleven point one to
eleven point two I learned that there
are some things were different region
Union used to accept a list for a region
Union and I could easily create like
this is this is with graphics 3d and so
it's easy to create something like this
and then region Union worked the same
way and I could just accept the list but
then in eleven point two I found I
couldn't do that I was getting errors
and I learned that I had to not have a
list so I had to apply a region Union to
my list which isn't that big of a deal
but I'm starting to think about how am I
going to teach my students how to do
this and so if they have to take that
extra leap in logic when they're just
learning Mathematica in the first place
this is the kind of something that's
going to create stumbling blocks for
them
likewise rotate rotate and graphics
piece of cake and no problem at all but
in
region with region plot 3d you have to
do a transformed region in a rotation
transform again once I figured that out
it wasn't too hard to deal with
but again thinking in terms of like
sharing this with lots of students and
it's just gonna be a little bit more of
a complication
so region plot 3d is certainly not as
intuitive as graphics 3d but I'm also
still learning some of the tricks of
working with that I know that there's
all these regions and meshes in
Mathematica and this is something that I
really just kind of worked with a little
bit and I know it's a big area also
leading toward 3d printing I did try
some things and this and I tried like
repair mesh but I couldn't get anything
to repair it wasn't working but maybe
that's better now I still have issues
with resolution it still doesn't get as
smooth this was the smoothest I could
get and this is supposed to be like a
squared off corner here not rounded like
this so a whole nother approach to
creating prints I got inspired with
trying to figure out how to take images
into 3d prints and I follow it along
with the guide page on the Wolfram
language gallery on how to make a 3d
image from an elevation map and having
flown over Mount st. Helens many times
in my life as my family travels from San
Diego to Spokane I wanted to try to
print it so just using the guide page
and entities here I pulled up the county
that includes Mount Saint Helens
took that section this was in the guide
page so I did it too and then I made a
list plot 3d and then applied the plot
theme film surface so the next thing I
knew is I had Mount st. Helens ready to
print and sure enough I did and I was
able to you know we were able to do this
in fact I'm just sharing this little bit
of code with another student for a final
project she's depict another mountain
and was looking at ingredients and all
sorts of things and had was able to
reproduce her own 3d print similar one
thing about printing with the styles
that the resolution is only as good as
the original image I had some I had to
estimate what I thought the appropriate
height would be because the blacks and
the whites were going from just zero to
one
and all of the pixels were the x and
y-axes
so it was like a pixel number so it
wasn't in like kilometers or some thing
that was relevant to the image and then
I was messing around with a picture of
my kids and I was hoping this would
still be getting passed around because
what happened here is I didn't even
bother to print this one because I knew
it just looked weird I'm like these are
my kids and it looks so strange and then
on Friday we were saying yeah the
printers open why don't I try to print
it and it looked kind of weird as we
expected but then I whatever reason held
it up to the light and all of a sudden I
had a photo of my kids in 3d print so
that was a really a treat so make sure
you get a bright light behind that one
to see it so yet another approach to
creating 3d models I wanted to create
something for our with our school mascot
logo here the Torrey Pines Falcons go
Falcons class of 92 and I got this from
one of our staff members as a PDF file
and figured out that if I did boundary
dust critize graphics I could get a
region from that because I had noticed
something I had never done before that
in plot 3d I can tell it to plot all X&Y
point plot the function over all
coordinates that are within the region
so just by creating that region and I
added a quadratic function to it I could
create this Falcon shape that kind of
lifts off the page then applying the
same technique I created my own PDF file
of the Falcons text but now instead of
applying a quadratic function I just
wanted it all to be the same height and
then putting them together here gave me
this and I added a cylindrical base and
created this final product and there's
actually a handful of them floating
around our school right now and it's
kind of fun to see that parametric plot
3d also what I when I did the Falcon
that was with filled surface as well
kind of like I did with the Mount st.
Helens parametric plot 3d I used the
plot theme thick surface in order to
have a surface to print I've also done
that with plot 3d as
well but I would I would like to be able
to control the thickness level so if any
of you out here in the audience have the
power to make that happen this is my
plea to you unless there's an option I
just haven't found in the documentation
center because you know that happens too
so I'd like to be able to have it be you
know maybe a little bit thicker or a
little bit narrower I'm sure with
additional work I could do that and I
created this cup this is kind of a low
resolution version of it because the 400
plot points was just going to make the
file size here too big but again I'm
using plot points to adjust the
resolution but that goes back to the
whole computational time and file sizes
and like I'm letting things render
before I go to bed and then hoping that
they look good in the morning kind of
thing maybe I just need a better
computer also the thick surface I've
come across I don't know if you can see
it here it has like these twists and
turns so it doesn't really have a flat
top and I knew that that would be an
issue for 3d printing so and I had to
use another piece of software to like
slice the surface because I wanted the
cup to sit flat and have a flat top on
the edge and I again this might be
something that's there and I just
haven't figured it out but it would have
been nice to have something like clip
Plains where I could actually clip the
surface and cut it off and in this other
program I was using that with just that
came with the windows I was able to cut
all sorts of things in half and so on
and even do this embossed text that
sound the example here - there's also
been a few times when I wanted I created
like an enclosed parametric plot 3d and
I wanted it filled in and I couldn't
figure out how to do that and maybe it's
a matter of making an adjustment in the
simplify 3d but it seems like there'd be
nice if there was a filled surface
option sort of with parametric plot 3d
as well so I'd like to share briefly
here as a couple of projects that my
students have done this is worth last
year projects Derek and Kathy got really
inspired from something they had done in
science olympiad
that was about wind turbines and turbine
blades so they initially created these
manipul
late so they could adjust the shape of
blades and then look did some other
shape adjusting manipulates and analysis
graphs and then they took what they
created and did print out 3d and they
did this a few times they designed their
own bracket to hold them together and
they were so excited they emailed me
this photo when they were able to get it
all together and I hope many of you got
chance to get your hands on this but
they actually hooked it up to a device
that they had created and spun it around
and took measurements and then they
printed more and more and more blades
because they wanted each one to have a
slightly different adjustment and then
they recorded their data and did
analysis and it was really fun to see
what they came up with and I had only
started working with 3d printing in
March and they were these are my
students now presenting this in May so
it didn't take much for the students to
get excited and get involved another
student will he was interested in the
brick ista chrome problem and looking
the you know seeing how a marble would
fall on a cycloid shape versus a
parabola or a straight line so he
followed basically the same technique
that I did to make the falcon head in
terms of using discretize graphics and
plotting 3d plot over the regions and he
made a cycloid and then turned it into
three dimensions and did all some
transformed regions and then we did this
he did this for the parabola and the
line and then kind of added some
additional graphics to make this ramp
and it was actually quite large it was
the largest thing we had printed at the
time and immediately I brought it to
class and I brought a few marbles and
the kids sat down and someone pulled out
their phone and did a slow-mo video so
we could see what would happen and
testing out the ramps and the result so
it's was quite powerful to be able to
take this idea that they had talked
about in physics and so get the right
shot here so you can see that it
actually wins
to take this idea that they'd studied
about in physics and then use
Mathematica to create something and then
we were able to print it and then use it
as an actual like physical demonstration
in class so that's what was exciting
examples of things you could do for
other classes a a teacher came to the
lunch room one day oh she was with all
these little pieces of paper that she
had cut out because she was doing these
different area problems with her
geometry class and I saw them and I was
in the middle of my 3d printing like
extravaganza I can do that so we we
custom design manipulatives that she
could use in class so there's like a
little tray and different colors and our
different tiles and different colors
it's they can demonstrate different
shapes and areas I brought these home to
my kids and even my three-year-old was
just absorbed in what he could create
with these manipulatives Anatomy plot 3d
I think we've seen this hand several
times at this conference already but it
was really fun to just take this and
just do print out 3d and it created an
STL model that we went ahead and printed
it still sits in my classroom with the
supports because we don't believe that
if we think that we take the supports
off the bones will start to fall apart
because they aren't really joined
together that well but it's certainly
interesting to look at and just kind of
opens up another world of possibilities
for what we could do for creating models
for other classes in speaking of biology
in there we have a class where the
students do gel electrophoresis to do
genetics work and the teacher has this
little comb that they use in their gel
beds to make little holes and this piece
costs between 20 and 30 dollars and she
needed to outfit her whole class for
them these were actually done by one of
my students who was also taking CAD at
the time so she did is in the CAD
program though it would be easy to see
how we could make these in Mathematica
and here we're now producing our
materials so that though they can run
their labs at a much cheaper cost and if
then what if we would had to purchase
them all even we met with the ceramics
teacher to learn about her workflow with
how she manages one kiln and all these
students who want to create their
ceramics because we're dealing with
similar issues with the 3d printer we
have two 3d printers but now I have my
math students and there's the CAD
students who the printers were actually
bought for and how do we start to manage
the use of those printers and making
sure people getting the cues the right
way so in talking with the ceramics
teacher about how she manages her class
we also got inspiration for other things
that we can do and using the same Falcon
head we created a custom stamp and it's
actually like filled with clay because
they've been using it to make
impressions on some of their their work
so what does the future hold one of the
things I want to start doing is actually
creating kind of lessons where my
students last year was all just kind of
this big party every day they look what
I made what I did here I'll share a file
with you but I wasn't able to do
anything systematically we now have
Mathematica and simplify 3d on computers
in my classroom so every student can
have access to this we also have the
printers set up for dual printing with
that just happen like oh the other
teachers set them up over the summer um
I haven't had access to the printers
over the summer and but I'm excited to
go home and start learning about
printing with two colors printing with
two materials using water-soluble
supports
there's all kinds of things that we've
been thinking about what we can do the
biggest issue for me is access to the
printers they were purchased for another
program within our high school and right
now that class is all beginning of the
school year those students haven't
gotten to the point where they're
printing but they will and it'll be
really hard for me and my students to
get access to them it's also in the
other part of our very large building
and I'm I only got a key to the
classroom like last week so I was always
interrupting other classes to get into
the room and there's just been kind of
just that access has been a huge
challenge for me I also feel like
there's still a lot to learn
some of these things that were
challenges I'm hoping that maybe some of
them are actually not so difficult to
overcome and I want to learn more about
when is it best to use region fly
three-d versus a mesh versus plot 3d and
so on
but it's clearly a fun and engaging way
to apply mathematics and mathematical of
the real world and it's and I always
felt that Mathematica let me take what
was in my head and really share it with
my classes but now it's like literally
bringing that to the next dimension
because we're now able to take these
models and the kids get their hands on
them and it's it's just it's just fun
this to see how much they're learning
and understanding is even moving forward
being able to to work with the 3d models
not only just you know being able to
have them in class but even those
students who invest the time and
interest into creating them themselves
and the whole all that they learn along
with that so thank you very much
[Applause]